el ex Primer Ministro de Pakistán y
arrancan debe ser liberado de inmediato
así lo ordenó la Corte Suprema de ese
país luego de tildar su captura como
ilegal su arresto había sido efectuado
por un grupo de pendiente del Ministerio
del interior el pasado 9 de mayo en el
marco del caso de corrupción que
enfrenta el líder político
lo primero es que el arresto de no es un
arresto sin un secuestro Estatal lo
segundo Es que la forma en que fue
arrestado demuestra que en este momento
no existe una constitución en Pakistán
hay un tipo de ley Marcial civil no
declarada
el gobierno de Pakistán acusaba al
político de 70 años de haber recibido
junto a su esposa tierras a través de un
fideicomiso caritativo por unos 117
millones de dólares pero los jueces
consideraron que no se siguió el debido
procedimiento de captura al ex Primer
Ministro quien fue destituido de su
cargo en abril de 2022 y ha sido acusado
en más de 100 casos de corrupción y
terrorismo
su detención detonó una serie de
violentas protestas en el país por lo
que el ejército fue desplegado ahora sus
seguidores celebran estamos complacidos
con la decisión de la corte Si no
hubieran liberado ahí rancan habríamos
derramado la última gota de Nuestra
sangre por él la Corte Suprema ordenó
alojar acá en una casa de seguridad
mientras se controla la situación de
seguridad en el país que deja varias
medidas de excepción como la suspensión
de los servicios de internet móvil